Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
You might have noticed that Sacha Baron Cohen,
the mind behind Ali G, Borat, Bruno, and The
Dictator, has a new show out.
With ‘Who is America?’
making Sarah Palin publicly complain about
being duped and Roy Moore threatening to sue,
it’s hard to miss.
"Is it possible to sign my waterboard kit?"
"Sure."
"Thank you.
Find a space."
"Right here."
But how does Cohen do it?
How does he keep getting such high-profile
people to make fools of themselves on camera?
Well, while he may land his bare ass on Eminem’s
face or wrestle the occasional fat dude, his
brand of comedy is more sophisticated than
you might think.
No, seriously.
"Maybe I'm mad, with this dream of becoming
a world famous artist, just by using my sh*t
and cum.
Am I?"
"I think we're all mad."
And it all has to do with clowns.
The creepiest kind.
So, come float with us for this Wisecrack
Edition on The Philosophy of Sacha Baron Cohen.
In case you don’t know who Sacha Baron Cohen is,
he rose to fame in the late 90s for his
brief segments on UK TV’s ‘The 11 o’clock
Show’ which also gave rise to Ricky Gervais.
His sketches were based around a character
initially called “the youth wanker.”
He was dressed like a stereotypical “chav,”
or – a British insult for obnoxious lower-class
kids – who had delusions of being part of
the gangster rap lifestyle.
"The member from Staines will be banned from
the house!"
"Is it coz I is black?"
That character transformed into what we now
know as Ali G. Ali G started by interviewing
British establishment figures with pompous
titles who were desperate to seem down-with-the-kids
but, predictably, this always back fired.
"What if, like Cleopatra, they bathed in asses'
milk?"
"In what?"
"Asses' milk"
Ali G often exposed how out of touch those
politicians and academics could be.
"It's much more democratic you see... than
the rap scene."
Within a year he won the British Comedy Award
for Best Newcomer.
His other characters Borat and Bruno were
also making appearances at the time, and they
all seemed to have the same kind of finger-on-the-pulse,
confrontational satire that had proved such
a huge hit with Ali G. Sure enough, 20 years,
four hit movies, and a major animation franchise
later, Cohen is back with his patented brand
of character comedy in ‘Who Is America.'
"Are these real hands?"
"No."
"They are... what?"
"Artificial.
Prosthetics.
Specially designed, they look just like my
real hands."
But his style of pissing off suits didn’t
just appear overnight, Cohen had training
from a surprising place.
In the mid-nineties Cohen attended an elite
Clown school in Paris, called ‘Ecole Phillipe
Gaulier’.
Alright, it’s not technically a clown school,
it’s a performing arts school, but it is
run by Master Clown Phillipe Gaulier, who
was a pupil of famous Mime and Performer Jacques
Lecoq, who followed in the footsteps of classic
cinema Clowns like Laurel & Hardy, Buster
Keaton, and Charlie Chaplin.
But before you start asking ‘where are my
oversized novelty shoes!’ clowns are more
than just red wigs and honky noses.
They have a pretty complicated history that
can help explain how we landed here: “Just
remember to point puppy pistol’s mouth right
at the middle of the bad man.
If he has a big fat tummy, point at that.”
"Ahahah, great.
It’s fun!”
Way back in Sixteenth century Italy, a type
of traveling theatre developed called ‘commedia
dell’arte’ that was performed on the back
of a wagon by actors in masks.
Which already seems creepy enough, even for
clowns.
Commedia dell’arte took the form of sketches
and improv with an elaborate bit of slapstick
performed in the middle by a character called
the Harlequin.
Well, sorta like her.
The Harlequin wore a checkered costume and
acted in silence, mostly so the actors didn’t
have to translate for the different Italian
dialects.
This section of the performance came to be
known as The Pantomime.
By the Seventeenth century, Pantomimes were
a whole show and contained a section called
the ‘Harlequinade,’ which introduced the
character called the Clown.
The Clown was created as a buffoonish companion
to the Harlequin.
Their physical comedy left a trail of destruction
behind them, a kind of humor that we see everywhere
around us today.
They were also boorish and crude, "Cuz me
nan's boyfriend, Derek, him always tell me
nan that he is cunnilingual.
How many languages does that mean him speak?"
And the word Clown originally meant ‘rustic’
or ‘peasant,' meaning they were used as
a depiction of the lowest class in society.
"He is my neighbor, Nursultan Tulyakbay.
He is pain in my assh*les.
I get a window from-a glass, him has to get
a window from-a glass."
These broader comedy moments of Cohen’s
characters certainly seem to live up to this
classical definition of a Clown, but in those
examples, the Clown is the one being laughed
at.
Cohen’s humor is unique in that it often
turns the tables and get the audience laughing
at, say, a Georgia state rep.
"I'll touch you with my buttocks!
I'll touch you!
You better drop the gun, or I'll touch you!"
Well, there’s a theatrical tradition to
that too - one that is inextricably linked
to clown-dom: the fool.
Building off commedia del arte, Shakespeare
– it’s always f**king Shakespeare – developed
the fool character in his plays which was
a mix of Court Jester and Clown.
He even occasionally called them Clowns.
And while they were certainly comic relief,
their other main role was to ‘speak truth
to power.'
The Fool in Shakespeare tends hang around
the important nobles, and in the process of
getting a laugh, they often unexpectedly have
something profound to say.
And if they can say whatever no one else can,
it’s because everyone discounts them as
an idiot, "Do you think President Trump – he's
your friend –do you think he might have
had a golden shower?"
"Wouldn't surprise me."
For example, in Shakespeare’s comedy “Twelfth
Night,” the character Feste is often called
a “wise fool” because he sums up the play’s
themes and gives an honest assessment of the
situation when other characters don’t.
For instance, when he’s asked to sing, instead
of just performing the Shakespearean equivalent
of ‘Despacito,' he sings a song that explicitly
states the play’s themes of young love,
it’s haste, and its follies: “Youth’s
a stuff will not endure.”
Another important element of the fool is that
their foolishness brings out the stupidity
in those around them.
In ‘A Midsummer Night’s Dream,' The Fool
character, appropriately called ‘Bottom,'
has his head literally turned into an ass
without realising it.
- yeah, Shakespeare wasn’t always subtle,
"This is to make an ass of me!"
He, then, is left to wander the forest where
he meets the fairy queen Titania who, under
the influence of a love potion, falls in love
with him, Ass head and all: “Thou art as
wise as thou art beautiful.”
Bottom remains unaware of his ‘condition’
so entertains Titania’s misguided affection,
which allows the audience to literally laugh
their asses off.
Bottom, just like Ali G or Borat, isn’t
mocking Titania.
He’s just an innocent fool; it’s Titania
that makes an ass of herself.
Similar to Bottom making an ass of Titania
by being an ass, Ali G uses his own assery
to bring out the ass in everyone around him.
"Wouldn't it be more better'n, instead of
having a voting age, just saying, 'Alright,
if you has got pubes, you can vote'?"
"Uh, it- I- you know, I- I- I would be willing
to try it in some smaller way."
In an early Bruno clip, Cohen interviews some
of the coolest, hippest, and wealthiest fashion
designers at a fashion show, one of whom has
produced a line of “trailer-trash” fashion
for the catwalk - yes, literally like Mugatu’s
“deralicte” from Zoolander.
Bruno asks her about this line of clothes
and prompts the stylist to be a little too
honest: “So tell me, do you hope that these
white-trashing people will buy the clothes?”
“I don’t think they can afford it.”
"They are too poor, HAHAHA!"
Cohen, is of course, aware that they can’t.
Asking, at a upscale fashion show, if poor
people can buy the clothes on display, is
stupid.
But this stupidity, is just a foil to get
them to reveal what Cohen already knows.
So you can see how Cohen takes this classical
archetype of a Clown, taught to him by Gaulier,
and brought it up to date.
But besides foolishness, the clown can also
bring out people’s, uhhh, less than pleasant
side too.
By incorporating a racial stereotype, nationalism,
or sexuality, a Clown can reveal prejudices
better than most.
So, when Borat sings, "Throw the jew down
the well," and people sing along —"Throw
the jew down the well!" — Cohen is baiting
people’s prejudices by mirroring them.
Or when Borat does this: "May George Bush
drink the blood of every single man, woman,
and child of Iraq."
Sure, it’s funny because we know he’s
being a Clown, but it’s also depressingly
revealing of public opinion during the Iraq
war.
When Bruno and his partner make out and start
undressing in the middle of cage fight, we
see the entire crowd doing this: "No....
Nooo!"
"You p*ssy ass, f****t motherf**ker!"
But if all Cohen is doing is making an ass
of people —"Go ahead, make my fifteenth
birthday, come on!" — what’s the difference
between him and an internet troll?
Trolls try to elicit a strong reaction out
of their audience, sure, but they’re also
hostile and negative.
The clown, on the other hand, has no malicious
intent; they’re just stupid.
A clown simply gives their targets enough
rope to hang themselves with.
"I didn't imply anybody here is racist, of
course not--" "I am.
I'm racist toward muslims."
But even then, whatever deeper purpose a Clown
has it should always come second to making
people laugh.
"Obviously the first aim is to be as funny
as you can, but, you know, occasionally, you
... you know, we end up uncovering some unpleasant
truths."
So, why do we think of Clowns only as white
make-up wearing and poorly sized motor vehicle
driving, child scarers?
What we picture when someone says ‘Clown’
today is known as the ‘Red Clown,’ which
was invented as a companion to the original
‘White Clown.'
The Red Clown was created in the 19th century
by actors and circus performers like Joseph
Grimaldi, George L. Fox and Tom Belling, who
obviously weren’t funny enough without a
red nose, and that's the image has taken over.
Today, whether it’s used as an insult or
to scare children: Clowns have an image problem.
A lot of that, argues Gaulier, is because
we’ve forgotten what a Clown actually is
and why Clowns like Cohen are so important.
A Clown isn’t defined by his make-up, which
has always been a muddle of different influences
anyway.
Per Gaulier, “Once a student has discovered
his Clown … he no longer announces with
his outfit … a Clown doesn’t need any
of that stuff; A Clown is innocent.”
This is what separates a real Clown from whatever
the hell this is.
A Clown should be invisible.
A Clown can slip amongst any group, particularly
the people who think that they're powerful
or successful, "We wanna say big up yourself.
Boutros, boutros boutros, boutros ghali.
Respect."
Because the Clown isn’t seen as a threat.
That’s how Clowns draw out their qualities
in these same people: like selfishness, foolishness,
childishness, clumsiness, and outright stupidity.
"'Merica!"
"Good."
Which is why someone like Cohen can get Pat
Buchanan to admit that: “Is it ever worth
fighting a war over sandwiches?”
“Is it ever worth fighting a war?
Um... yes.”
Or this: "In less than a month — less than
a month — a first grader can become a first
grenader."